[Música]
olá tudo bem
hoje vou falar um pouquinho sobre o
sport por uma vida mais feliz e eu
escolhi esse tema porque gosto muito de
praticar esportes também porque gosta de
ajudar todas as pessoas de qualquer
idade e qualquer esporte traz muitos
benefícios às pessoas
o esporte faz muito tempo a saúde é
claro que você já deve saber isso
mas esse não é pouca coisa ele faz bem
pro corpo pra mim que precisamos
circulatório respiratório para os ossos
para os músculos e muito mais
ele também ajuda a combater a depressão
ele também proporciona vários
sentimentos que você nunca soube por
exemplo imagina que você foi lá treinou
bastante e chegou o dia do seu jogo você
foi lá e você ganhou
além do mais os seus parentes vieram de
assistir com tudo isso você ficou muito
feliz
você acabou se sentindo motivado porque
você ganhou
você conseguiu só que dessa vez quando
você foi tentar de novo não se acabou
perdendo e você fica triste mas você
pode tentar de novo e dessa vez você
pode conseguir
e vamos supor que você tentou e você
conseguiu
olha que coisa boa em um dia você pode
perder e ganhar
olha que para que legal eu nem precisei
falar mas já dá pra ter uma idéia você
se dedica para um jogo você tem você se
sente segura quando você pratica
bastante quando você treina bastante
você tem que ter paciência para o jogo
começar
você se sente motivado quando você perde
e quando você ganha você se sente muito
feliz
você se sente alegre quando você ganha
quando sua família seus parentes nem se
assistir
você fica triste quando você perde e
você fica ansioso para o jogo começar
você sabia que o sport também pode nem
você é uma amiga sua
ou você é um amigo seu o também seu país
com o outro por exemplo em 1950 ocorreu
a guerra da coreia do sul coréia do
norte
elas ganharam até 1953 até 2017 elas não
se falavam
mesmo se tinha uma
metade da área da coréia do sul e até da
coreia do norte elas não se falava até
2018 porque em 2018 ocorrer os jogos
olímpicos de inverno que a coreia do sul
ea coreia do norte debateram pra poder
entrar com a mesma maneira nos jogos e
se é um esporte de ter convidado elas
não teria cor não tivesse ocorrido pode
ser que a maioria da população não teria
entendido
então agora é sua vez de praticar o
esporte assim como eu e muito obrigada
pela atenção
[Aplausos]
[Música]